I mean it's funny I did a TV show reason
i rarely do TV I it's pretty corrosive
for journalists print journals like
myself but i did a this week which is a
great show cool you know cool venue and
uh and bob rice was on one side of me
and George will was on the other and
they were having an argument at the
economy George will was saying look at
the stock market and look at the
indicators and the economy is terrific
and the economy is not an issue in this
campaign and Bob rice was saying look at
inequality and look at the housing
market I'm telling you the economy
people are anxious the economy is going
to be a big issue in the campaign what I
was thinking to myself did not have the
courage nor the time to say is you know
you guys don't get it it's not the
market indicator it's not the housing
slump and it's not the stock market
today or six months from now or six
mother is a 30-year underlying anxiety
and by the way I think Bob Raj does get
this so I want to be fair there's a
30-year underlying anxiety in American
life about economic opportunity and it's
not dependent on the indicators of the
day and when gas prices go up it gets a
little bit worse and when gas prices go
down it might get a little bit better
but generally speaking there you know
we've had for you know two generations
essentially a deep fear about what
economic changes is wreaking on the
society and and and and and and what it
means for their children because that is
really the American ethos it sounds like
a cliche but if you tell people who work
in mines or work industrial jobs that
their income potential that their their
their personal potential is going to be
limited but their children's will not
they're okay they would take that I
think we all care about the
opportunities our kids have it's why
we're here it's the deepest thing we
hold about the American ideal we've made
it into the cliché of the American dream
but it's not a cliche it's actually a
deeply held value and people have great
anxiety about it and it's the issue in
every campaign and it's going to be the
issue in this campaign as well and and
and and and so will foreign policy
because I think September 11th is a
defining event in some way a lot of
Democrats now don't think it is I think
it is I think
because people do feel a sense that what
happens in the world now affects them
and this is really the thread that runs
through all these sort of emerging
issues economically foreign policies
we've where we've now entered a time in
American life for all the reasons we've
talked about technologically and
socially where we no longer dictate all
the terms we're not self-sufficient we
actually are affected by what some you
know bunch of homicidal you know
terrorists hatch up in an apartment in
Berlin Berlin or bond somewhere we're
actually affected by the economic policy
that China pursues or that or that
Venezuela pursues and so you know it's a
very insecure time because we're used to
dictating the terms to everybody else
militarily and economically and and the
question is you know for leaders in this
country is what are you gonna do about
that what's your vision for adapting to
it and what's missing from the campaign
is any greater discussion of what that
that change looks like it's any hard
truths it's any it's any any answer for
any problem that might not immediately
be popular with the broader swath of
people that's what's missing